welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 8 of She-Hulk
filled with Easter eggs a lot of devil
in the details and some big hints for
the finale I thought we'd go through it
scene by scene to talk about the things
you might have missed not you
specifically mate I'm talking about
someone else anyway come with us as we
break down the entire episode and also
offer up our theories if you enjoy the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this almost every day by
the way thank you for clicking this and
now let's get into She-Hulk episode 8.
foreign
[Music]
which is a catchphrase a leapfrog also
known as both LeapFrog and Frogman in
the source material and the comics
Frogman was a pretty funny character who
followed in the footsteps of his father
to do all the things a lot and in the
source material Eugene patillo's dad was
a failed inventor with them all being
kept afloat by his mother this led into
them constantly struggling and Eugene's
dad Vincent ended up creating
electrically powered coils that allowed
him to jump more than mortal men ever
could he became the criminal LeapFrog
but after he was caught he ended up
going to prison Eugene discovered his
costume and realizing that he didn't
want to become a criminal he became a
Force for good they changed things there
for the episode with Eugene's dad being
rich and due to the arcade cabinets we
see I'm guessing he made a bigger sleep
frog though she G never has the shame of
the LeapFrog Legacy that he does in the
comics and so he doesn't become frog man
instead they flip things around so that
Eugene is the bad guy or as in the
source material it is of course his dad
own the source material though he's
helped out a lot of crime Fighters he's
also sort of always been the butt of the
joke Frogman in the comics can of course
jump really high but due to how clumsy
that the suit is he finds it really
difficult moving now this place into the
episode with a costume having a major
malfunction because of the Skies of LA
and over here two thieves loading a TV
into their van they argue over whether
it's OLED a qled but we can see from the
box that it's an LED black levels mate
they're not gonna be as good if you have
ever had a conversation with me if
you've ever been that unlucky you'll
know I'm proper into TVs and stuff I've
got two lgo LEDs in the hizzy and I was
the guy who told Tom Cruise to turn off
his motion smoothing I'll bring this up
because I've never heard the name Lin's
Cog however doing a quick Google search
brings up that this name actually
belongs to a law fair Mountain Sweden
which might be why it's included here
maybe I've just been blind and never
seen them but uh let me know fam now
Kermit that wasn't a daredevil pun by
the way now Kermit arrives at this point
and he introduces himself as God frog
which is of course a play on guard dog
time to read it and rip it
he ends up fighting with style and then
he flies up in the airway ends up
falling with style too he has angle jet
boosters similar to Star-Lord and these
enable him to take off with us getting a
similar shot to Tony taking off in the
first Iron Man movie as he comes
crashing down we also hear this sound
might be reaching but I think this is
pulling from the sound effect archives
and giving us the same sound we get when
the Millennium Falcon breaks down
foreign you could say that he's the
Millennium frog
now we see that he's telling this story
to Jen and that he's also got third
degree burns due to the jet booster
setting on fire also important to note
that Jen's wearing a suit that fits her
She-Hulk form added donning lots of
men's clothes earlier in the season now
this ties into LeapFrog suit as well as
it's made by Luke Jacobson and thus it's
almost a conflict of interest to sue him
Holloway does push Jen down the root of
serving Eugene even though it could
cause issues with Luke they also bring
up the gala again which foreshadows the
ending now Holloway is a character that
we haven't really talked about all that
much but there is a clue in the comics
as to what's going on with him it was
revealed that Holloway actually set up
the entire superhero division so that he
could get his granddaughter South poor
out of prison she was the super villain
that he was trying to reform and he put
Jen in charge of looking after her he
figured that this would give his
granddaughter a mentor figure to
gravitate towards and it would also give
Jen some responsibility in the comics
she was constantly out partying and
getting drunk and looking after South
Pole would help to ground hair we still
don't know what the case is that Titania
interrupted in episode 1 and it may tie
in with that or a character that we
haven't met yet either way he's an
important person to bear in mind and his
motivations behind hiring Jen could end
up being similar to The Source material
Cody Jacobson who talks about her dress
being ready for Friday so she can
collect her award again this is the gala
so I'm just pointing that out now Luke
doesn't take too well to being sued and
neither does the dress he's working on
which again pops about the gala you can
you can see the sequence and everything
now after the title sequence we jump to
court and at this point we get a big
entrance by Matt Murdock though he comes
in making jokes I do like how they
playing with him clearly knowing the law
even all at what ifs and ways to
navigate keeping things a secret you
also get a big big line about the
sokovia records being repealed Now
remind you that the sokovia courts have
been repealed soup this is very
important as they were put in place to
make it so that all heroes had to be put
under check by the government this was
based on the Superhuman registration act
that appeared in the Civil War storyline
and many fought for keeping their
identities a secret so that
supervillains couldn't hunt them this
happened in the case of Peter Parker and
Aunt May who was even shot after Kingpin
sent an assassin after him them being
appealed means that Spider-Man and the
MCU doesn't have to reveal his identity
and sadly I don't think we'll ever find
out who's really beneath that mask now
Jen actually represented several
characters in the comics that tried to
appeal the Accords and when they were
moved to a prison in the negative Zone
she was the only one who provided their
defense similar to the comics Jen chose
to reveal her identity and thus she's
sort of seen as being a bit biased which
is why she tries to help out those who
want to remain anonymous in the Court
Eugene reveals that he used jet fuel
which was against the advice of Luke
this is sniffed out by Matt but the
issues for Jen don't go away now
speaking of issues we had men appear in
the dance slot run on number of issue 8
he stood in an elevator alongside
She-Hulk and this image was adapted into
the one that appears in the credit scene
She Hulk and Matt have faced off against
each other in court and this also came
in She-Hulk vol 3 issue 8. after Luke
says he hates her we cut to the legal
bar and see Matt sending her a green
apple teeny sorry Matt didn't see you
there and this is where he starts to
give some life lessons he's Charming
dashing and it's good to have him back
there was a time I thought Netflix might
have killed him off and I might have
killed them but we can all relax now
because he's back and killing it he
confirms a lot of the original Netflix
Origins story including his law firm in
Hell's Kitchen which does a lot of pro
bono work this is what Matt and foggy
started doing in the Netflix series with
foggy constantly wanting to make money
but he was reined in by Matt Jen then
touches upon the secret life of Matt
Murdock which no price for guessing what
that's a reference to now Daredevil
traveled from New York City well we're
not in New York City today ever since
Matt Murdoch showed up in Spider-Man no
way home we've been desperate to see him
back in his suit and this new look is
fresh for the full collection whereas
the previous costumes were created by
Melvin the last time we saw him he was
being taken into custody so Matt is now
going to Luke Jacobson who is a
character from the comics that makes
superhero outfits you might remember
that at the end of Daredevil season 3
that Matt was wearing his original
homemade costume and now he's had to
reach out to others since Melvin is
probably locked up Marvel Studios have
put together elements from both the
Netflix series and also his classic look
from the comics The Source material
originally had him donning a yellow
undersuit and a black boxing leotard
which was inspired by his father in case
you don't know Matt's dad was a boxer
that refused to throw a fight and then
he was killed by Mobsters because of it
some depictions have this being carried
out by the Kingpin but on the whole most
of them just have it being random
members of the mafia which is what
inspired Matt to become a crime fighter
in both the courtroom and Hell's Kitchen
now imagine again have a sort of Willy
Wonky thing going on this episode but
they do hook up even though he could
probably smell the dude on her breath
from episode 4. Charlie Cox has
confirmed that he'll only be showing up
in one episode but we know that he will
also heavily feature an echo before
going off into his own series titled
Daredevil born again this is based on
the Frank Miller Story but it also of
course is a meta joke on how the
character is now born again at Marvel
Studios just this week Daniel rpk posted
out that Echo will feature in that show
as well so we are slowly watching as all
these properties tie together I imagine
that this series will likely set up Echo
and also even the next Captain America
movie which we'll talk about at the end
either way Daredevil is clearly here to
show her that she can do good with both
gen and also She-Hulk the former can
help out when Society fails people
whereas the ladder can be there when the
law fails them now it's great that they
kept most of the writing the same on
Matt and after Hawaiian Kingpin I was
worried he'd come in busting puns about
how Justice is blind he does do some
some stuff like that but it's more
keeping in line with his charm and I
like the way they dial it back for the
more serious moments now Jen gets a text
from Todd at this point I'm guessing he
got her number from when they went on
that date Together Matt also gets called
out urgently like it's some Superman
thing similar how Clark will get called
away he gives up his personal life to go
and do crime fighting and it shows the
duty of a true hero at the restaurant
Todd brings up a wakandan war spear that
he bought at an auction these are of
course carried by the door milage and
they're very expensive due to being made
out of vibranium Todd is a weird
character as it was leaked in early
screeners for the show that his name
appeared as Hulk Todd in the credits it
was either Hulk Todd or Todd Hulk I
don't know but either way we've been
saying since about episode 4 that we
think he's the one who jabbed Jen in the
arm when he was part of the Wrecking
Crew really where she'd ask wrecker last
week what that was all about and then we
wouldn't have to spend hours every week
talking about theater time if the credit
leak is right though then Todd could end
up becoming a Hulk himself and this
would all tie in with a blood God and
those who want to create their own we
only have about 20 to 30 minutes left of
an episode next week though so I don't
know if they even have time to wrap
everything up but that's just what I'm
imagining at the moment now in episode 4
he asked about whether vibranium could
pierce his skin the intelligencia which
I think is how it's pronounced then
change the needle to a vibranium one and
it is possible that Todd bought the
spear and then they melted the metal
down in order to make the needle the guy
runs off in a mask at the end and
personally I think this is him
underneath it he does a cringy wakanda
forever and it turns out that the
wakandans want this beer back because it
was stolen by colonizers wakanda forever
oh I I that makes me uncomfortable I
don't think you can give it back because
again it's melted down and he tries it
on with Jen again showing what this
meeting was actually about Jen returns
home to get a call from Eugene and
similar to what Matt said she can
protect people both legally and
physically as the character She-Hulk at
this point she busts out her costume
which as we guessed it was handed to her
by Luke back in episode South 5. now
she-hulk's costume is based heavily on
several looks that she has in the comics
the suit is evolved over the airs and
it's constantly made use of the white
and purple here they actually pull
across some of the elements from the
suits used in endgame and the black was
something at Hulk War whilst carrying
out the blip there's also some concept
art that shows the way the purple panels
are laid out against the White and it
does remind me a lot of the way that the
quantum suits appeared in that movie all
the way back in Age of Ultron Hulk
started wearing Spandex and he of course
suggested that Jen got some 2 which it
appears like she's done either way the
new suit looks awesome to me and I think
it's really in line with the comics
whilst also feeling like it's part of
what's come before in the MCU now from
here we go to a parking lot to see
mountain top of Eugene's green car which
of course ties in with his costume she
help ends up stopping it which causes
Daredevil to flip over it busting out
those amazing acrobatics I love the way
we get a slow pan up of his costume with
us moving up from the stomach to the
face to show it off I know people
groaned at the ass remain and whoop line
when this scene was released on Twitter
last night but Daredevil does burst out
stupid jokes occasionally in the comics
and I won't Braille against him for
doing a dumb pun they've also really
nailed the way that I think Daredevil
moves in the comics he flips around and
swings through the crack that She-Hulk
creates before descending quickly from
the car park it's all really smooth and
well put together making him move like a
highly trained athlete Jen also punches
the ground and this is pulling from the
cover in the Dan's [ __ ] She-Hulk run she
also bursts out the Thunderclap which
she does in the comics and of course did
in the first episode hope Jen doesn't
give Matt the thunder clap later on
now when Jen and masks him we can also
see a sign in the background for Rogers
the musical which of course appeared in
Hawkeye and it also showed up at the
start of no way home we also get notes
from the Daredevil Netflix score again
confirming it's all connected gold devil
I'm Daredevil
haven't done it all connected in a while
but we're bringing it back we're
bringing it back now we jump a Tilly
frog space which is called the lily pad
here we get a QR code and scanning this
will give you access to She-Hulk 9 which
featured an old Captain America this is
the issue that follows on from the one
we talked about earlier showing it and
I'm gonna do it again it's
are Eugene sitting an almost poison ivy
type Lair forcing Luke to sew away and
making even more complex costume he
wants a suit to get a fancy British AI
in it and this is of course a nod to
Jarvis be careful though mate not all
not all British accents are are as
pleasant to listen to as that in that
white mate ain't that right in the
background we see artwork of the
character and this pulls directly from
the comics Daredevil wants to take the
stealth route whereas Jenna's happy just
smashing and dashing like my man Matt
does later on what this does is lead us
into a daredevil hallway fight scene
which we're of course pioneered by the
Netflix creators I'm really glad they
decided to include one of these in the
episode and as Matt says he's done this
before the Hawaii fight scenes are
always really memorable and it's a
brilliant way to show them off they keep
the lighting blue giving it a certain
style and though they don't do it in one
take you can't tell they're paying
attention to what's come before in the
lily pad we can also see that LeapFrog
has a frog signal which is of course
similar to Batman's bat signal now as
you know zero Edition has all the heavy
spoilers merch you need you're probably
aware that may real Rejects and Screen
Crush have a little competition behind
the screens and we want to bring it to
you on October 11th in a live stream an
exclusive live stream exclusive
exclusive exclusive exclusive in that
we're going to be talking a lot of crap
but also unveiling our new designs and
t-shirts that you can get exclusively at
xeroedition.com in the live stream we're
going to break down the design so come
chat with us as we go through it all and
just you know generally talk about pop
culture and all the things we're
enjoying at the moment and some of the
things we're not before this drops
though you need to get your hands on the
bully spoilers shirt before it's gone
for good don't miss his exclusive T
because once it's gone it's then buried
like Uncle Ben and all those copies of
Batgirl while you're at it on
xeroedition.com also pick up the power
and responsibility t-shirt or the genosa
Community College we've hand-picked the
material on the shirts made it so that
it's fitting to all body types we
haven't just thrown this together me
Greg and Ryan work really hard on it
it's high quality material high quality
prints and we want to bring it to the
fans as a thank you for supporting us
for so long this is the best way to
support the channel and get something
back for you and we work with Zero
edition every single month to bring you
new and exclusive shirts also if you buy
from my shop I get Ryan's dog at least
promise I've made a deal he hasn't
agreed to it but I'm making that deal
right now so all of this is just a shout
out the shirt and be on the lookout for
the live stream on October 11th make
sure you check it out hopefully I see
you there tag us on Twitter and yeah
just come join in the fun it'll be a
great time cheers now inside the lair
Jen smashes up one of the arcade
cabinets and we also see one for Frogger
don't know if you kids know what this is
but just in case you don't this is
actually an old game that me and the
other old people used to play back in
the day didn't need Ray tracing back
then just the open road and The Great
Outdoors Jen and Daredevil burst up some
heads and LeapFrog once more causes an
injury to himself showing that he's
still a [ __ ] Luke forgives Jen and then
drops a line about her not getting fat
at which I think is a comment on the
movie industry making girls stick to a
certain weight there was a big thing
with Alicia silverstone's weight when
she played Batgirl and it could be
referencing how much pressure Hollywood
puts on women to look a certain way Matt
has one night left in LA and it's time
to Hulk smash that pasty before he goes
home as much as I've been [ __ ]
Daredevil as well I do think that this
is probably gonna be a divisive
interpretation of it and if people
kicked off about the twerking thing then
they'll probably get annoyed by this too
if you've been following our She-Hulk
videos and you'll know I haven't enjoyed
the show that much but I think they
managed to keep things in the tone of
the series with Daredevil not stepping
too far out from what you'd expect let
me know below if you think they missed
the Mark or not but either way I think
the episode should have ended at this
point like Jen says however we need a
tease for the finale and this comes in
the form of the gala in the build up of
this Jen mentions Red Hulk which of
course comes from the comics and also
the phrase fridging his term was coined
by Gail Simone and it came off the back
of Green Lantern 54. in that his
girlfriend was introduced and then when
he returned home he found him murdered
with her body stuffed in a refrigerator
fridging refers to when a character is
introduced to beasts something that the
protagonist can invest their hot into
only for them to be brutally killed off
this gives the hero motivation to fight
the villain and Simone criticized it for
being a way to push male characters
forward through using a female that gets
killed before they're properly developed
from here we head to the gala where we
see the dress completed and all eyes on
Jen here her parents return along with
Todd really Todd and the host says this
line and doing everything regular
lawyers do except backwards and in high
heels now this is a reference to the
saying that was coin and Frank and
Earnest it refers to how when women
dance with men that they have to do
everything they do but they have to do
it backwards and in high heels it's far
more difficult but they only get the
same praise that men do without an
appreciation for the talent that's very
much the case here and it turns out that
lots of women get the award and it's
more of a participation thing for the
company to basically virtue signal to
the masses Mallory also gets one too and
she is an interesting character when we
look at the comics she ended up becoming
an enemy of Jen due to her constantly
causing chaos in her life though they
work together for the Titania case I can
see the tides turning and she may end up
being a mid-level villain that reports
to the higher-ups known as the face who
never lost Decay she ended up becoming
part of the shadowy organization that
tried to create their own version of
She-Hulk if that sounds familiar which
it should then that could be what's
happening with the intelligent share
during the scene in which they looked
over the group Mallory was adamant that
they don't reveal this to Jen and he
could end up being either part of them
or not now she also clearly worked with
Todd 2 and has at least a professional
relationship with him she pleased with
Jen not to destroy the screens and now
she might just be trying to offer some
kind words it might also be Henning is
something more but let me know below at
this point hulking comes on screen and
this Anonymous s group have hacked her
entire life due to Josh cloning her
phone on this screen we see her message
from Todd and also two pictures of
Captain America's ass one of which was
used for her phone background there's
also shot of the airport fight from
Civil War and we can catch both Black
Widow and Spider-Man as well lastly it
ends with it being revealed that Josh
filmed their night together and this
pushes her over the edge to finally
become the angry monster that Bruce
warned her about again this is the
person who I think is Todd he looks
quite similar with his sunglasses at
night and he clearly had his face for a
reason and because of that I think it's
gonna be a review later on damage
control show up and we can see that they
have modified versions of the Hulk
Cannon used in The Incredible Hulk they
also have the Sonic guns that we've seen
him as Marvel and that takes us into the
credit scene this contains Todd bidding
alongside Eugene for the wakandan spear
we also see Matt's mask with a bra on
top of it and a Jacob beside it lastly
we see him walking along the street
we're saying whilst Nikki takes a photo
now so next week I think Jen's gonna
have to show how she's still a
law-abiding citizen whilst also dealing
with the damage controlled soldiers she
also have to prove the intelligencia
behind this but with there being a
blackmail video I can see that being
pretty easy I do think Bruce will have
to return and calm things down and then
she'll finally see she can listen and
take his advice rather than casting it
to the side he of course left a guard as
a car after he was summoned there and
that happened so long ago that had
almost forgotten about it there's been
rumors for years now that we are getting
a World War Hulk movie and with
abomination She-Hulk and the blood plot
akansius getting to that point although
that's a major event in the comics I
actually think it might end up being
similar to the world war Hulk storyline
that has an S on the end has to have an
S otherwise it's not the one I'm talking
about and that featured several hulks
all checking it out including Red Hulk
and Red She-Hulk who could be introduced
down the line it has been rumored that
Harrison Ford was asked to replace
William Hurt his General Ross and that
wood sign with the Red Hulk thing too I
think the leader will probably play some
role next week and then that will sign
the Captain America New World Order yeah
we know that Tim Blake Nelson is
returning for the role as the leader and
just being a Hulk villain it makes sense
that he'd use that to set up things
involving the Hulk specifically you also
have Titania who's still out there and
I'm expecting her to basically be the
big bad before we get a tease to the
other ones working behind the scenes New
World Order makes me think of the
Illuminati and the intelligent [ __ ]
seems to be a similar sort of
organization they also have modak as a
main member who we know will be
appearing in Ant-Man Quantum Mania so
it's all coming together for us to get
this big cabal anyway that's the episode
and I'm so glad that it managed to do
Daredevil right on the most part for me
he hit a lot of the Beats I expected but
like I said I can see it being divisive
however for me he worked and I'm glad
that he wasn't just one note one thing
I've often criticized the show for is
having slightly underdeveloped
characters and many of the cameos have
either been there for comedic's sake or
just to add some minor things towards
the plot it didn't really feel like they
had much depth or as Matt Murdoch's
Daredevil debut bring brings a lot with
it and makes it feel like he's part of
an almost different show at times not
not completely but bits here and there I
think getting him right was a very
important thing as it of course also
shows what where they're going to be
taking the character in the future he's
going to be showing up an echo and also
in his own Disney plus series I think
this probably will be seen as the best
She-Hulk episode and even though I think
the season has been disappointing I did
enjoy this one anyway let us know your
thoughts below as well as what you want
to see in the next one we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of dollar and thunder on
the 15th of October and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our Brighton of the Black Panther
wakanda forever trailer which will be
linked on screen right now if you go
over all the Easter eggs in it talk
about the characters so definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thank you for clicking the video I've
been Paul I'll see you next time take
care peace